MANN, NO.
BARTON 'GOT IT.
BARTON FOR THREE -- IN AND OUT.
JOKIC SCRAMBLED FOR IT.
>> I BELIEVE THEY ARE GOING TO
CALL A FOUL ON NIKOLA JOKIC.
>> LET'S SEE IF THE NUGGETS WANT
TO CHALLENGELE THIS.
>> IT'S A TOUGH PLAY BECAUSE
IT'S A LOOSE-BALL FOUL.
>> YOU CAN'T TAKE THEM WITH YOU.
WILL BARTON TAKES THAT THREE.
THEY ARE BATTLING UNDERNEATH AND
THEN YOU SEE THE BALL COME OUT
HERE.
TWO OKC PLAYERS.
>> THE QUESTION ISES TO MICHAEL
MALONE WANT TO USE THE TIME-OUT.
>> WELL, JOKIC IS BLEEDING,
DRIPPING.
THEY MIGHT NEED TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT.
>> PLAY WILL CONTINUE.
07-05.
IT.
A MINUTE LEFT TO PLAY.
MONTE MORRIS WITH THE BIGGEST
PLAY OF THE NIGHT SO FAR.
>> MORRIS HAS BEEN SPECTACULAR,
RUNNING OFF SCREENS AND EARLY ON
THE HELP SIDE --
>> JOKIC WITH 32 POINTS.
LONG RANGE MORRIS!
YES!
MONTE MORRIS!
WITH A HUGE SHOT.
MONTE MORRIS STEPPING UP ON BOTH
ENDS OF THE FLOOR WHEN DENVER
NEEDED IT.
COMING ACROSS SEEING THE ROLL
BEING THERE FOR THE HELP.
JUMPING TO TAKE THAT STEAL.
MONTE MORRIS RELOCATES A LITTLE
BIT HIGHER SO JOKIC CAN SEE HIM
IN THE PASSING LANE.
JOKIC THROUGH MONTE MORRIS
STEPPING IN AND DOWN READY SHOOT
UP AND THAT'S AS GOOD AS IT
GETS, IF.
>> RIGHT NOW THEY ARE WORKING ON
?OK.
JASON MILLER, THE DOCTOR TRYING
TO PATCH UP THE EYE.
HE'S DOWN AND READY.
JOKIC 32 POINT, 12 REBOUND, 8
ASSISTS AND A CUT.
>> HE'S ALSO GOT A DOUBLE,
DOUBLE WHICH MEANS IT'S DOUBLE,
DOUBLE TIME, TOMORROW WITH ANY
PURCHASE YOU CAN GET A FREE
SIX-PIECE NULGT SPICY, REGULAR,
WHATEVER YOU PLEASE.
>> NUGGETS FANS ARE INTO IT
TONIGHT.
MONTE MORRIS, A HUGE DEFENSIVE
PLAY AND